[Music]
he thought this was supposed to be the
most advanced security system on the
planet we don't have all day
how he acted um until you have satellite
of course
are you certain the target is in sight
oh she's here alright okay
[Music]
I cannot wait until the inspection is
over
the door I am in position summer time to
target incoming right now
chairman boys care venue guidance
systems there will be the difference in
destroying the havea Dominic's tell me
we're still on schedule
the omnium will not wait for us be ready
before they attack again
our first new mix in a decade this will
ensure the future of Russia just a
little further
small-scale let's go ah we don't make
her hold the perimeter
we'll take over
Sombra I'm cut off it's on you now I'm
all over it
ah
get away
Oh back fire on catwalk level 3 Sombra
status
[Music]
yeah what's Scott down
you have no idea what it took for me to
make this meeting happen well a hot day
I'm not going to give you I mean I'm the
one that said of the alarm
Sombra do you have the target okay
listen I'm here to make a friend and
show you something I found tell me what
would happen if the people of Russia
learn that their defender against the
omnec was actually getting her Tech from
the enemy what would that do to the
future of Russia
what do you want the most powerful woman
in Russia okay
I've always wanted a friend like that so
I'm thinking I don't let these images
appear on every Hall of it in the world
and you help out your new friend every
now and then what do you say clock's
ticking Amiga
as if I had the choice
now what friend
I'll be in touch
mission failed target escaped get back
to the ship
Oh
[Music]
do you know why you are here
hmm I believe I do
you
you